BUT FIRST, THE ANGLES G.O.P.
PLATFORM FOR 2020, THAT’S A
FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S ANGLE.
THE PAST SIX MONTHS HAVE BEEN --
TO PUT IT MILDLY A VERY
DIFFICULT TIME FOR THE COUNTRY.
FIRST THE DEMOCRATS DRAG THE
NATION THROUGH THE PHONY
IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDINGS WITHOUT
EVEN SPECIFYING A CRIME AND THEN
THE CORONAVIRUS HIT.
A BLUE STATE GOVERNORS DECIDE TO
FLATTEN THE CURVES BY FLATTENING
OUR ECONOMY AND OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
NOW WE ARE IN THE MIDST OF MASS
DEMONSTRATIONS AND STILL SOME
WRITING BREAKING OUT IN MAJOR
CITIES.
WITH A 2020 ELECTIONS NOW JUST
FOUR AND A HALF MONTHS AWAY OR
SO, THE G.O.P. HAS TO MAKE SURE
IT’S PLATFORM ACTUALLY SPEAKS TO
THE HORRORS AND THE HARDSHIP
THAT THIS COUNTRY IS
EXPERIENCING.
THE BEST DAYS ARE INDEED AHEAD
OF US, NOT BEHIND US.
WE HAVE SOME PLATFORM
PREREQUISITES.
FIRST WE WILL REDOUBLE OUR
EFFORTS TO PRESERVE FOR ALL
AMERICANS OF THEIR FREEDOM OF
SPEECH, FREEDOM OF RELIGIONS,
FREEDOM OF PRESS AND FREEDOM OF
ASSEMBLY.
WE LOST A LOT MORE THAN JUST OUR
BOOMING ECONOMY AND THE
LOCKDOWNS AND EVEN WITH STATES
REOPENING COMP MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS ARE STILL UNABLE TO
ATTEND CHURCH SERVICES, GO TO
WEDDINGS, OR ANYTHING FOR THAT
MATTER ARE SACROSANCT FREEDOMS
SHOULD ONLY BE ABRIDGED IN TRUE
EMERGENCIES.
AND ONLY PURSUANT TO LAWS PASSED
BY ELECTED OFFICIALS.
NOT BY DECREES ISSUED BY
GOVERNORS OR MAYORS.
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO DON’T EVEN
FOLLOW THEIR OWN RULES.
>> CHICAGO’S MAYOR
LORI LIGHTFOOT IS SPOTTED
BREAKING SOCIAL DISTANCING TO
GET A HAIRCUT.
>> GOVERNOR PRITZKER OF ILLINOIS
SINCE HIS FAMILY TO FLORIDA AND
THEN LOCKS ON THE WHOLE STATE
AND TELL THEM WHAT THEY CAN’T
DO.
>> WHILE GOVERNOR WHITMER WAS
URGING PEOPLE TO STAY HOME OVER
MEMORIAL DAY WEEKEND, MARK
MALORY IS PUSHING TO GET HIS
BOAT IN THE WATER.
HE TRIED TO NAME DROP THE
GOVERNOR TO GET IT DONE.
>> Laura: NUMBER TWO.
WE WANT PROSPERITY FOR ALL
AMERICANS AND TO ACHIEVE THIS
GOAL WE WILL PROTECT BASIC
PROPERTY RIGHTS.
BUT WE WILL ALSO STOP EFFORTS BY
MULTINATIONAL COMPANIES TO SHIP
JOBS OFFSHORE.
THINK ABOUT IT, 21 MILLION
AMERICANS ALMOST ARE DRAWING ON
AN APPOINTMENT RIGHT NOW AND
WHILE THE JOBLESS RATE IS COMING
DOWN ST3 OPEN, SO INSTEAD OF
CONGRESS GREEN LIGHTING MORE
DEATH FUNDED, AMERICAN WORKERS
DO NOT HAVE TO COMPETE UNFAIRLY
WITH FOREIGN WORKERS.
NOW TRUMP HAS DONE THE
UNIMAGINABLE BY BRINGING CHINA
TO THE NEGOTIATION TABLE WITH
TARIFFS AND BY REPLACING THE
DISASTER THAT WAS KNOCKED OUT
WITH THE USMCA.
BUT WE NEED TO DO A LOT MORE.
WE COULD START BY BRINGING BACK
OUR MEDICAL SUPPLY CHAINS FROM
CHINA.
THE COUNTRY OF COURSE THAT
UNLEASHED COVID ON THE REST OF
THE WORLD.
NEVER AGAIN SHOULD WE BE HELD
HOSTAGE BY THE CCP.
WHEN THE NEXT PANDEMIC HITS, WE
WANT ALL AMERICANS TO FEEL SAFE
INSIDE AND OUTSIDE OF THEIR
HOMES AND THAT MEANS SWIFT AND
SURE PUNISHMENTS FOR VIOLENT
CRIME ESPECIALLY IN POOR
NEIGHBORHOODS.
IT ALSO MEAN SUPPORTING THE MEN
AND WOMEN WHO PUT THEIR LIVES ON
THE LINE EVERY DAY TO PROTECT US
US.
>> STOP TREATING US LIKE ANIMALS
AND START TREATING US WITH SOME
RESPECT.
NOBODY’S TALKING ABOUT THE
POLICE OFFICERS THAT ARE KILLED
IN THE LAST WEEK AND IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
>> WE HAVE TRAGEDIES LIKE THE
COLD-BLOODED MURDER.
WERE THE THREE OFFICERS IN
BUFFALO WHO WERE RUN OVER, BY A
PEACEFUL PROTESTER.
AND HE MAY BE ON A VENTILATOR
FOR THE REST OF HIS LIFE.
BAD COPS SHOULD BE WEEDED OUT,
COPS WHO COMMIT CRIMINAL ACTIONS
SHOULD BE DATE JAILED IN THE
PUNISHMENT SHOULD BE SEVERE.
THE FUNDING POLICE BECAUSE OF
THE EVIL ACTS IT’S DANGEROUS.
WE ALREADY KNOW WHAT A POLICE
FREE SOCIETY LOOKS LIKE.
>> RESPONSE TIMES FOR CRIMES IN
PROGRESS WERE OVER 15 MINUTES,
ABOUT THREE TIMES AS LONG AS THE
AVERAGE OF EVERY YEAR.
IF THAT IS YOUR MOTHER, YOUR
SISTER, YOUR COUSIN, YOUR
NEIGHBOR’S KID THAT IS BEING,
ROBBED, ASSAULTED AND OTHERWISE
VICTIMIZED, YOU MIGHT HAVE TO
REPORT THAT IT TOOK THE POLICE
THREE TIMES LONGER.
>> Laura: AT THE COMMUNIST
PARTY IS A GREAT THREAT TO THE
UNITED STATES AND WILL TAKE ALL
MEASURES NECESSARY TO PREVENT IT
FROM ENDANGERING OUR INTERESTS.
AND, TECH COMPANIES WE ARE
TALKING TO YOU.
AND THAT MEANS NO MORE CCP
FUNDING FOR AMERICAN UNIVERSITY.
LET’S GO, THEY HAVE TRAINED SO
MANY OF THE CHINESE COMMUNIST
PARTY’S BRIGHTEST MINDS TO GO
BACK TO CHINA TO ULTIMATELY, I
NEED TO TAKE A VERY HARD LOOK AT
THE VISAS THAT WE GIVE THE
CHINESE NATIONALS TO COME TO THE
UNITED STATES TO STUDY.
>> Laura: NUMBER FIVE.
WE BELIEVE THAT AMERICA REMAINS
THE BEST HOPE FOR A BETTER LIFE
IN A BETTER WORLD.
AND WE PLEDGE TO TEACH OUR
CHILDREN THE TRUTH ABOUT THIS
COUNTRY.
BOTH THE GOOD AND THE BAD.
AND TO ENCOURAGE THEM TO HONOR
THE SACRIFICES OF ALL THOSE
PATRIOTS THAT COME BEFORE US.
>> THAT’S BASED NOT ON WHAT --
ON WHAT IS IMPORTANT.
WE KNOW THAT FREEDOM REQUIRES A
FIGHTING SPIRIT.
TYRANTS BOTH LARGE AND SMALL
HATE THIS COUNTRY, THEY HATE ITS
FREEDOM.
THEY WANT TO FORCE US TO LIVE
UNDER RULES THAT THEY MAKE UP.
LAST UNCHECKED, THEY WILL CREATE
A DIVIDED COUNTRY AND A DIVIDED
WORLD WITH THE RULERS ENJOYING
SPECIAL PRIVILEGES AND THE
RULES, WELL, YOU WILL JUST BE
TRAMPLED.
>> AVERAGE AMERICANS HAVE FOUGHT
AGAINST THE SORT OF TYRANNY AND
WE PLEDGE TO CONTINUE THIS FIGHT
NO MATTER THE ODDS.
AND TO GIVE OUR CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN OF ALL RACES AND